they sure don't make movies like they
used to when I was a kid yeah
now they have sound cool here are two
young stars who did a lot of traveling
in the movies this year she went on the
trip to bountiful and was in passenger
on a runaway train
he drove a souped-up sports car and back
to the future please welcome Rebecca De
Mornay and Michael J Fox
with art directors are sex for example
if you went to the movies this year you
visited a strange metropolis in Brazil
art direction by Norman Garwood said
decoration by Maggie gray
Juke join in a Georgia swamp in the
color purple our direction by J Michael
Riva and Robert W Welch set decoration
by the end of December a coffee
plantation in Out of Africa
art direction by Steven Grimes set
decoration by Josie McGavin a Japanese
for in Ron art direction and set
decoration by Yu Shu Ouma rocky and
shinobi Meraki
on his farmhouse in witness art
direction by Stan Joe Lee set decoration
by John Anderson the winners are Steven
Grimes crowd of Africa
first of all I want to thank the man
above the Academy yeah Sydney [ __ ]
and congratulations - thank you